hey everyone welcome to this week's live
session
today's topic is web developer roadmap
for 2021
but before we begin i'd like to thank
our viewers for tuning in and
actively participating in these sessions
let's wait for a while
for the people to tune in
also we have a dedicated team to answer
all your queries
so if you have any questions let us know
in the chat section we'll get back to
you
all right i see a few more people have
joined so this session will be about
today's topic
which is web development roadmap in 2021
so let us begin assuming that you know
what web development is
the roadmap is divided into three
sections the first section is
all about the common skills which every
web developer
should know while the second and third
are about
front end and the back-end development
the main areas of web development
so you can either learn front-end or
back-end
or both depending upon your choice so if
you want to become a full-stack
web developer then you have to learn
both front end and the back end
there is no escaping there in the end we
will also go through the salaries of
web developer so without further ado
let's get started
the first one that is the common skills
let us understand the basic skills that
you require to become a web developer
there are a few recommendations in that
you must learn for either path
these are the common things every
programmer should know
the first one is git get is a free
and open source version control system
that enables collaboration
in a particular project it is designed
to handle both
small and large scale projects git is a
tool used to save code and create
different versions to better manage the
feature updates in a product
or application the next one is
the data structures and algorithms a
data structure is a location
used to store and organize data an
algorithm
is a collection of steps to solve a
particular problem
learning data structures and algorithms
will allow us to write efficient and
fast computer programs
followed by data structures we have the
text editor
get familiar with the text editor of
your choice
next visual studio is the top choice of
the most web developers
and my personal choice too because it
has a large support of
languages and of course the speed
next text editor is where you write all
your code and the terminal is where you
execute it
so followed by the text editor we have
the command line
a command line is the important tool
that you need to get familiar with
it is how you run your code after
writing your code on the text editor
the better you are on the command line
the most efficient you will be as a
developer
so followed by command line interface
you have the http
or https the http protocol is a backbone
of the internet
it handles the requests and responses of
a web application
it is mandatory for a web developer to
have good knowledge of
both http and https in order to build a
fast and responsive web application
so followed by common skills we have the
front-end developer
front-end development is all about
developing the user interface
and its interaction with the client end
let's go ahead and look into this field
of web development
there are a few things that you must
know for becoming a front-end developer
let's discuss these things so the first
one is
the web development basics it is
necessary to know the basics of web
before moving on to programming
languages
next you should know stuff like a web
applications
protocols like http and web development
in general
so followed by web development basics we
have the html and
css html and css are the backbones of
any website html provides the structure
while css provides the style to make
them visually appealing
mastering these two technologies is a
must to become a front-end developer
browser in the end renders html and css
on the web page
regardless of the technology used to
develop that page
followed by html and css we have the
javascript
javascript is an extremely important
technology that every web developer
should learn most of the popular web
frameworks like react.js
and node.js are built upon the
javascript
javascript makes the web applications a
love by adding interactivity and dynamic
updating of web applications
followed by javascript we have the
typescript
typescript can be considered as an
extension of javascript
angular uses typescript as a space
language
it adds type safety to javascript to
cache errors in the development phase
it also helps in developing object
oriented code for javascript
so followed by typescript we have the
angular
angular is a web framework used to
create a single phase
applications it is backed by google
therefore learning angular is a good
choice for a modern
web developer so followed by angular
we have react js react is a popular
library for developing fast and
responsive web applications
it is backed by facebook and quite
popular because of its simplicity and
performance
it allows you to create a reusable
components that can be used to create
modern web applications so followed by
react.js we have
view js view is like other frontend
frameworks that is used for building
user interfaces it is comparatively
easier to integrate
view with other libraries or existing
projects
it is a newer framework but it has
really picked up speed last year and
being adopted
more now followed by the front-end
developer we have the back-end
developers
so back-end development is more about
caring how application works and
ensure that it keeps running smoothly
let's go ahead and know more about this
field of web development
there are a few things that you must
learn for becoming a back-end developer
let us discuss those things
so the first one is the node.js node.js
is a javascript runtime
built on chrome's v8 javascript engine
it allows you to develop a complete web
application using javascript
it is best suited to be used for web
applications in conjunction with
javascript frameworks like
react.js so followed by node.js we have
python
python is a popular language used in
various fields of tech applications
django is a backend framework based on
python used for server-side scripting
it is also known for its speed and
efficiency python is also
easy to get started with programming
language if this is your first time
coding
followed by python we have java
java has been the most used language for
a long time
it is primarily used for back-end
development you can either use core java
or java with a spring boot for high
performance back-end
next we have next we have ruby
ruby is a dynamic programming language
that focuses
mainly on simplicity it has a syntax
that is very easy to read and close to
english language phrases
the web framework ruby on rails is
popularly used for developing packing
systems
so followed by ruby we have php and
mysql
php although treated as a hard to learn
language
is still the easiest way to write server
side code
at least 50 percent of the internet runs
on php and mysql
mysql is the most popular database for
storing data
of a web application now followed by the
backend developer we will enter
the next important stage of web
development roadmap in 2021
that is about the web developers salary
trends
let's now have a look on the salary
trends of a web developer
web developers are always in demand
since new web applications are launched
and managed continuously they are
generally offered
generous salaries across the globe
salaries also depend on the types of web
developers
for instance full stack developers are
paid more than the front-end and
back-end developers
the average salary of a web developer in
india is 3 lakh 86 000 per annum
the average salary of a web developer in
the united states is 68
524 us dollars per annum there you go
we have discussed possibly everything
about roadmap to become
a web developer in 2021 we have
youtube playlists that cover everything
from every basics of html and css
to advanced web development frameworks
don't forget to check those out
if you are interested in web development
the links are added in the description
box below
and with that we have reached the end of
this video hope you liked it
think we missed out anything important
let us know in the live chat or in the
comment section below if you are
watching this later
thank you for watching this video and
stay tuned for more from simply learn
you